♪ ♪
>> ON THE SIDE OF FREEDOM YOU
HAVE THEORLD'S RICHEST MAN
ELON MUSK GETTING ONE STEP
CLOSER TO LIBERATING TWITTER
FROM CENSORSHIP CRAZY LIBERALS.
THE CEO SS THAT HE SECURED
MORE THAN $46 BILLI FOR ITS
POTENTIAL TAKEOVER AND ON THE
OTHER SIDE YOU HAVE
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA WHO'S
SHING FOR MORE
ONLINE.
>> THE FIRST AMENDMENT I THE
CHECK ON THE POWER THE STATE.
IT DOESN'T APPLY TO PVATE
COMPANIES LE FACEBOOK OR
TWITTER.
WHAT CONNT MODERATIONAN
LIMIT TH DISTRIBUTION OF
CLEARLY DANGEROUS CONTENT.
IT IS GO FAR ENOUGH.
SO MUCH AROUND THE CONVERSION
OF DISINFORMATION WHAT PEOPLE
POST.
THE BIGGER ISSUE IS WHAT CONTENT
THESE PLATFORMS PROTE.
>>ET READY FOR MORE THIS DONE
BY A NEW STUDY BY THE DE MEDIA
RESEARCH CENTER.
THEY'VE CENSORED BITAND
CRITICISMS, 646IMES OVER TWO
YEARS.I CAN READ OUR AN OBAMA SH
OUT FREE SPEECH AND
DISINFORMATION AND CONTENT
MODERATION.
EY NEVER TALK ABOUT WUHAN LAB,
NEVER TALKED ABOUT RUSSIA
COLLUSION THIS INFORMATION WILL
EXPENSE OVER THE COURSE THE
DIMENSION STEVE BANNON'S OTHE
WORLD THAT ARE THE REAL THRT.
Jeanine: IT'S THE TIMING OF
ALL OF THIS.
NOWHAT WE HAVE ELON MUSK
GETTING CLOSER TO TAKING OVER
TWITR BARACK OBAMA FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNIT STATES
COMES OUT AND STARTS TALKINGABOD
THE MODATION OF THAT CONCEPT
THAT IS SO FUNDAMENTAL TO WHO WE
ARE ANIMATES IS THE FREEST
COUNTRY IN T WORLD THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AND THE FREEDOM
TO SPEAK AND PRACTICE RELIGION.
IN THE FREEDOM TO ASSBLE.
ALL OF THAT ISUNDAMENTAL TO
WHO WERE AND THIS CONCEPT THAT
SOMEHOW THEY CAN STOP US FROM
COMMUNICATING AND MAKE NO
MISTAKE.
WE COMNICATE BY EMAIL YEARS
AGO WE WOULD'VE DONE IT BY MAIL
WE DOING IT BY EMAIL AND THEY
ARE LOOKG AT OUR COMMUNICATION
MY EMAILS, MY LETTERS TO ANOTHEY
THAT, YOU CAN'T SAY THAT.
WERE GONNA TAKE YOU OFF SO YOU
CAN REPEAT THIS.
THIS IS THE ANTITHESIS OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND WHAT
FREE SPEH IS ALL ABOUT.
WHATBAMA IS DOING AS IF HE IS
CULTIVATING NOW THE CONCEPT THAT
WE CAN MODERATE THINGS LIKECONTE
CAN GET RID OF DISINFORMATIO
WHICH LEADS US TO THE PLACE
WHERE IF YOU DON'T AGREE WITH
WHAT THINK YOU WILL BE SHUT
DOWN WE'VE BEEN BATTLING THIS
SINCE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN CAME
AND EVENEFORE THE ELECTION.
ALSO THE NEWSPAPER CANNOT BETRAR
COMMENTS ABOUT WHAT IS IN THE
NEWS ARE 51 INTELLIGENCE
OFCERS LYING AND SAYING IT'S
DISINFORMATION.
DO THEY THINK THAT WE ARE STUPID
THAT THEY NEED TO TELL US WHAT
WE CAN AND CANNOT REA THIS
INFURIATES ME.
HE IS WRONG ON THIS THIS IS
UN-AMERICAN, FREE EECH IS
FUNDAMENTAL AND WE LOSE IT OR
GONE.
>> OBAMA ASSIGNMENT ON THE
FIRST ENDMENT FUNDAMENTALIST.
YOU CAN INFRIN ON THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
UNDERMINING FREE SPEECH THE
HAROLD I THINK IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE FREEPEECH IS NOT ABOUT
PROTECTING FREE SPEECH THAT WE
REE WITH.
IT ABOUT PROTECTING SPEECH
THAT WE DAGREE WITH AND IS IT
BETTER THAT WE ALL ENGAGE IN E
ARENA OF DEBATE AND IDE IN THE
BEST IDEAS WILL RISE TOHE TOP,
HA NOT BEEN THE ARICAN WAY?
>> WITHOUT QUESTION.
>> I THINK MORE FREE SPEECH
ABSOLUTIST OVERALL CAN'T YEL
FIRE IN A CROWDED FEED THEATER.
WE SEE A COMMON CASE IN VIRGINIA
BASED ON LIABLE DEFINITION.
THERE CERTN THINGS YOU CAN'T
SAY THAT LAW PROTECTS.
THAT BEINGHE CASE ARE RIGHT INTE
OF US HEARKENS BACK TO THE
CONVERSATION WE WERE HAVING
AROUND EDUCATION SOM OF THINGS
ARE BEING TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS I
THIN IT'S IMPTANT THAT WE
ESENT IDEAS TO UNSETTL PEOPLE
TO HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS AND
HAVE THE DEBATES.YOU ARE THE BET
RISE AT LEAST WE INFORM AND
EDUCATE PEOPLE BUT WHA THE
ISSU ARE WE SHOULD NOT BE
MIAKEN.
'S A RICHEST MAN INHE WORLD
HE MAKES ELECTRIC CARS HMAKES
BATTERIES.
REVISE BATRIES.
ILLNESS OR ECONOMI THIS GUY
KNOWS HIS WAY AROUND A BALANCE
SHEET.
I DBT THAT HE WOULD BE DOING
IT.
>> IS AWARE THAT THE FOUNDERS
WANT TO NISTRY OF TRUTH WE
WANTED TO ACTUALLY LET DEBATE
HAPPEN?
>> LISTEN TO A BARACK OBAMA SD
THAT THE FIRST AMENDMENT IS ONLY
CHECK ON THE STATE.
MAKES IT WONDERING WHY'D THEY
DON'T WANT THE FIRST AMENDED TO
APPLY TO BIG CORPORATIONS AND
CORPORATIONSSPECIALLY THAT
MAKE ALL THEIR MONEY ON SPEECH.
PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO TALK ABOUT
THGS.
THEN I LOOK BACK AT WHO
PRESIDENT OBAMA REALLY IS IS A
STUDT OF ZELENSKYY ANY TREATS
IS TO TROLL INFORMATION THEY
CONTROL THE MEDIA YOU CONTROL
EVERYTHING.
CLEARLY DAEROUS CONTENT.
FOR THE LAST CLEARLY DANGEROUS
CONTENT LIKE HUNTER BIDEN'S
LAPTOP.
IT'S THINGS ABOUT THE WUHAN LAB.
IT'S BASIC THINGS ABOUT GENDER
AND BIOLOGY AND SO THEY SHIFTED
FROM ACTUALLY DANGERO CONTENT
TO ANY KIND OF CONTENT THAT THEY
DEEM A RISK FO THEIR POLITICAL
PRPECT AND THAT'S WHY THEY
HAVE NO GREAT ABILI ON THIS.
I THINK IT'S HIGHLY ALARMING
THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENTS
PERFECTLY FINE WITH HIS MONSTER
CORPORATIONS GOING AFTER CERTAIN
SPEECH THAT HE SIMPLY DOESN'T
LIKE.
>> GREG FINAL WORD?>> Greg: WHEE
SNOW FIRST TO MIMIC
SOAL MEDIA PLATFORMS BECAUSE
THERIVATE IS ACTUALLY RIGHT
BUT IT'S ALSO WRONG BECAU
THE PLATFORMS BEEN THE SINGLE
MOST DOMINANT PLATFORMS FROM THE
EXCHANGEF INFORMATION RIGHT?
SO THERE ARE LIKE OTHEREDIA
ENTITIES.
I THINK WHAT HE DOES IS HE WANTS
JUST LIKE FOX NEWS FOR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."IN WHICH TN
FOR US TO HOST OTR PEOPLE'SIDEAN
COME ON HERE AND I'M SAYING?
THAT IS NOT THIS.
DENYING ACCESS TO FACEBOOK OR TO
TWTER IS ESSENTIALLY DENYING
ACSS TO THE MODERN TOWN
SQUARE.
IT'S NOT LIKE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" OR AN
OTHER PLACE.
THE BIGGER ISSUE WHICH I TOUCHED
ON IS YOU CANNOTRUST THE
CREDIBITY OF ANY PARTISAN
POLITICIAN WITH AN IDEOLOGY TO
MONEY OR MODERATE CONTENT.
BECAUSE WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO GET
HIS CONTENT REMOVALS THAT ONLY
FLS IN ONE DIRECTION.
HEOULD CALL VIEWPOINT
DETERMINATION.
IT ONLY WORKS ON BEHALF AND THIS
CASE WHEN Y LOOK AT THE HUNTER
LAPTOP RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
IT SEEMS ONLY FLOW ON BEHALF OF
THE LEFT WHICH IS WHY THEY DON'T
MIND BUT ONCE HE GETS MORE
BALANCE AND LET'S SAY YOUO
HAVE ELON MUSK TAKE OVER TWITTEE
BECAUSE I'VE NO IDEA WHAT HIS
POTICS ARE.
E IS PROBABLY LIBERTARIAN BUT
AN OLD PIECE OF A RUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT.
I FIND THAT REALLY HEALTHY AT
THAT I DON'T KNOW.
ONCE THATAPPENS YOU MIGHT SEE
VIEWPOIN DETERMINATION HABIT IN
BOTH DIRECTION BECAUSE I PUT
OUT A VIEWPOINT AND THE SOMEONE
PUTSUT A COUNTER VIEWPOINT AT
ALL SHOWS UP ON TWITTER.
THAT'S THE WAY IT SHLD BE
>> THEY'VE BEEN TING TO CENSOR
TALK RADIO FOR EVER SINCEHE
90s.
>> IF WERE ABLE TO CENSOR OUR
OPPONENTS WHEN WE RAN FO
CONGRESS THE POWER OF TH